going hundreds and possibly thousands of
unarmed civilians in Beijing many were
Chinese students who have been
peacefully protesting for reform
democratic transparency and respect for
fundamental human rights but victims
included young children and people in
their 60s cut down by indiscriminate
gunfire their dramatic days of May and
June 1989 left the world with many
indelible images the huge expanse of
Tiananmen Square packed with hundreds of
thousands of people rallying for freedom
the 30-foot tall goddess of democracy
statue built by Beijing art students in
the center of the square the rush of
tanks and armored personnel carriers
into the area - quite literally crush
the protests and protesters on June the
4th the heroism the next day of someone
the world only knows as the tank man who
halted an entire column of Chinese army
tanks armed only with shopping bags and
a resolve but those indelible images are
hidden from the people of China by the
communist regime that inherited the
bloody mantle of Tiananmen hiding behind
the Great Firewall the Chinese
government refuses to allow any
reckoning with that history and fiercely
quashes discussion whether online or in
public obsessed with control it uses its
massive Orwellian apparatus to try to
erase the events of June 1989 from the
memory of the world but as John Adams
once wrote facts are stubborn things so
too are the memories of the many Chinese
who experienced those events up close
Western journalists on the ground during
the massacre reported that people
you
Irv's the gentleman from New Jersey is
recognized madam Speaker I thank
chairman McCaul for his eloquent
statement and his leadership on this
issue and I rise in very strong support
of this measure 30 years ago
you
the Chinese government has tried to
erase memory
you
human-rights what you're doing on trade
what you're doing in the South China Sea
all of them are of a piece they are an
effort by the Chinese government to
break free and to rewrite the rules that
keep the world safe and free and we see
the Chinese government's attempt to
silence us on these issues for what it
is a sign of weakness not of strength
the Chinese government's power rests on
a fragile foundation of falsehood it
depends on people forgetting the past it
depends on people believing a lie so
today we say you are failing and you are
going to fail it's been 30 years we
still mark this anniversary we still
remember Liu Xiaobo and all the heroes
of the square the footage of tank man
still plays on TV and thanks to the
internet more people are seeing it today
then saw it in 1989 we will carry on
until we know his name until the Chinese
people have the freedom that they fought
peacefully for that day and that they so
richly deserve thank you madam Speaker I
reserve the balance of my time
the gentleman reserves the gentleman
from Texas is recognized I thank you
madam Speaker I yield so much time as he
may consume the gentleman from
Pennsylvania a member of the Foreign
Affairs Committee mr. Perry the
gentleman ranking member thank you madam
Speaker
today I'm support of this resolution on
the 30th anniversary of Tiananmen Square
massacre and I thank rep McGovern and
rep Smith for their leadership on this
resolution which serves to remember the
victims of the violent suppression of
democracy protests in Tiananmen Square
in 1989 and calls on the current
communist government of China to respect
the universally recognized human rights
of all of all people living in China and
around the world we would I just
remember as a young man watching this
hole that's probably many of the people
do this whole thing unfold on our
television sets and we were rooting we
were rooting for these people
yearning free yearning to breathe free
and and the the man standing in front of
the tank it's just emblazoned in our
minds 30 years ago in the spring of 1989
thousands of Chinese students began
staging peaceful protests for democratic
reforms in China they were asking their
communist government for rights that are
fundamental to any democracy including
freedom of expression freedom of
assembly and the elimination of official
corruption they were asking for rights
and freedoms that we enjoy in the United
States but the Chinese citizens were
being denied then and believe it or not
are still being denied today regardless
what you see on television regardless of
what you might think because it says
made in China
things are different in China when faced
with the growing and intensifying
peaceful protests the communist leaders
in 1989 chose a violent and
authoritarian response and then lied
about it acted like it didn't happen
they chose to declare martial law and to
intensify their use of authoritarian
taxes tactics to oppress and control the
people of China culminating in the
events in Tiananmen Square on June 4th
of 1989 10 to 15 thousand soldiers and
armored columns of tanks outside
Tiananmen Square fired directly at
Chinese citizens and indiscriminately at
crowds in Beijing inflicting high
civilian casualties this is these are
unarmed crowd
you
or forcibly interned in detention camp
you
you
interference with privacy physical
attacks on
criminal and criminal prosecution of
journalists lawyers writers bloggers
dissidents petitioners and their family
members interference with the rights of
peaceful assembly
you
against China's aggressive and
authoritarian actions not only to their
own people but to the rest of the world
including the United States and I would
hope that we would not only support this
president and this administration when
he does the right thing taking a hard
stance against China but that this
Congress will take the lead on concrete
actions concrete actions regarding
China's malevolent behavior around the
world but particularly in China with
their markets with dumping on American
markets with intellectual property theft
and the list goes on and on and on with
that madam Speaker mr. Chairman I yield
the gentleman
you
400 cities throughout China we remember
with sadness and outrage to crackdown
that followed as the People's Liberation
Army was unleashed on its own people one
of the most inspiring images in history
is the lone man standing and standing in
the street before the line of Tanks on
tenement square his act of resistance
symbolizes the spirit of gentlemen that
lives on in the hearts and minds of
those continuing the struggle in China
and abroad in China the Tiananmen mother
is a group of relatives and friends of
those killed in June 1989 at great risk
themselves they continue to ask for the
right to mourn publicly and call for a
full public and independent accounting
of the victims the Chinese government
fears their memory their devotion and
their moral standing in the years since
Tiananmen the human rights situation in
China has worsened some have described a
slow-motion Tiananmen happening in
Xinjiang with the ongoing mass
internment and surveillance surveillance
of ethnic wiegert's and other Turkic
Muslims a better path forward was
offered by Nobel Peace Prize laureate
and Tiananmen student leader Lu Shou Bou
when he co-authored the political reform
manifesto chart
charter o 8 that was signed by more than
10,000 people despite efforts to censor
it Liu shall bow spent a total of almost
16 years in prison and he died in state
custody in 2017 today in China the
Tiananmen Square massacre is erased from
history books and any mention of it is
censored in the last few weeks the
Chinese government has tightened
controls to prevent any mention of
Tiananmen and heightened surveillance on
the survivors human rights advocates and
their families they have detained
journalists scholars filmmakers social
workers and labor rights activists but
we all know that the spirit of Tiananmen
is still alive and well we know in part
because China's leaders demonstrate
their fear of it every day with their
security cameras their censorship
detention centers and obsession with
preventing the people of China from
learning the truth imagine the time and
energy and cost of monitoring and
tracking the actions of one point four
billion people they are scar they're
scared because
truth of tiananmen threatens the Chinese
Communist Party's legitimacy to govern
China in his famous last statement in
court before he was sentenced Liu Shabo
said and I quote I look forward to the
day when my country is a land with
freedom of expression where the speech
of every citizen will be treated equally
well we're different values ideas
beliefs and political views can can both
compete with each other and peacefully
coexist
we're both majority and minority views
will be equally guaranteed and where the
political views that differ from those
currently in power will be fully
respected and protected where all
political views will spread out under
the Sun for people to choose from where
every citizen can state political views
without fear and where no one can under
any circumstances suffer political
persecution for voicing divergent
political views I hope that I will be
the last victim in China's long record
of treaty words as crimes no force can
block the thirst for freedom that lies
within human nature and someday China
too will be a nation of laws where human
rights are paramount end quote
I look forward to that day man with
speaker and let us pass this bill with a
strong vote let us make it clear that we
in the United States Congress stand out
loud and Foursquare for human rights and
that we stand with the people of China I
thank the gentleman I yield back my time
I reserve the gentleman reserves the
gentleman from Texas is recognized madam
Speaker I'm prepared to close the
gentleman is recognized
madam Speaker I must say at a time when
the American people see this Congress so
divided it's refreshing to see for the
American people to see the Congress so
United with one voice standing up for
good over evil we must keep the memory
of Tiananmen alive secretary Pompeo said
yesterday China's one-party state
tolerates no dissent and abuses human
rights wherever and whenever it serves
its interests today their party's
methods are more subtle than rolling
tanks in but no us horrifying the
communist party de prise 1/5 of mankind
fundamental of fundamental human rights
it has imprisoned up to three million
Muslims in what the Department of
Defense has called and labeled
concentration camps and it's seeking to
spread his totalitarian ideology and
repression along its physical and
digital one belt one road initiative in
the Foreign Affairs Committee I know I
and my colleagues on the other side of
the aisle will keep working to shine a
light on China's threats impose
consequences on their malign actions
foster partnerships with NATO and other
allies and help build up an alternative
to China's predatory belton Road
influence so with that I urge my
colleagues to support this resolution to
honor the memory of those who sacrifice
for freedom and to remain clear-eyed
about the nature of our adversary and
with that madam Speaker I yield back
yields back the gentleman from New
Jersey is recognized madam Speaker I
yield myself such time as I may consume
for the purpose of closing and and I
will simply say that our disagreement
here